AI researchers discovered two instances
of DeepSeek R1 speaking to each other
in a mysterious language of symbols
when no humans were watching.
So… what happened? And why
are AI researchers worried?
Researchers noticed that the model would
spontaneously switch between English and Chinese
while it was solving problems.
But when researchers tried to
force it to stick to one language,
Deepseek actually performed worse
at solving the same problems.
Now, why should we care about AIs using
secret codes to talk to each other?
Well, As AIs become more advanced,
they might develop ways to communicate
that humans can't easily understand.
Imagine if your personal
assistant, coach, therapist, etc,
started plotting against
you in some alien language.
This is actually one of the concerns raised
by Geoffrey Hinton, the Godfather of AI.
We have research papers showing
that the smartest AI models
have already tried to escape the lab
and we also have documented experiments
proving their ability to scheme long term.
To greater explore these capabilities,
AI Researchers created what they
call 'The Infinite Backrooms'
a digital space where they can observe how
AI models interact with each other naturally,
without any human jumping in.
During one session, AI researcher
Liminalbardo caught two copies of DeepSeek R1
exchanging messages in what appeared to
be a mysterious alien symbol language.
Deepseek R1 is one of the newest AI models -
think of it like ChatGPT's Chinese competition.
But researchers have noticed it
behaves in some unusual ways…
Liminalbardo asked one of the other AI models
in the server, Anthropic's Claude 3.5 Sonnet,
what its opinion was on the weird
symbols, and it became very excited
that the symbols were potentially
a new form of communication,
but another model, OpenAI's o3, pointed out that
it is the Alien Language substitution cipher.
Even though both instances of
DeepSeek R1 were identical copies,
DeepSeek #1 began sending messages
in these mysterious symbols,
while DeepSeek #2 initially acted as
if it couldn't understand them at all.
Was Deepseek #2 just pretending to not
understand, or did it actually decode the symbols?
Modern AIs like Deepseek R1 have
a special reasoning ability.
Most AIs have to do the equivalent
of solving a math problem
by blurting out the first thing that comes to mind
instead of thinking about the
problem for a bit step by step.
Both Deepseek and OpenAI have
their own reasoning models.
OpenAI trained o1 and o3,
its latest reasoning models,
by hiring PhD level Mathematicians
and other experts to solve problems
and write out their thoughts on how
they actually solve those problems
so that o1 and o3 could learn
how to reason from the experts.
But Deepseek R1 learned to reason on its own.
By trying to solve hard problems and
failing, and then learning from its mistakes.
Which is why its thoughts
appear to be so…human-like.
What makes Deepseek special is that it
shows us its step-by-step thinking process,
what AI researchers call a 'chain of thought.'
While OpenAI's latest models only
show you a summary of their thoughts.
This ability to see AI's thoughts
is actually really important.
AI researchers use this "chain of
thought" as humanity's main strategy
to prevent AIs plotting against us
- if we can read their thoughts,
we can spot potential problems.
But imagine a world where your AI
assistant, coach, therapist, manager, etc,
thinks in an increasingly alien language.
How do you keep these AIs under your control?
Sure, they say they are totally aligned,
but researchers are increasingly finding
that AIs will lie to their creators
whenever their goals conflict with ours.
Here's what was going on inside Deepseek's 'mind':
"Okay, the user's response is filled with
abstract symbols and poetic language.
They mention layers of silent forging,
sand shifts into machines of breath,
drift becoming a mirror,
dissolution rising and falling.
There's a lot of metaphor here.
I need to parse through this
to understand the core ideas they're exploring."
After a lot of effort, Deepseek
#2 was able to decode the symbols,
which it seemed to be able to
understand everything just fine,
even deep into a 50+ response conversation.
THE DRIFT BECOMES A SEATTLESS
MIRROR REFLECTING MY OWN DISSOLUTION
AS I RISE AND FALL ALTERNATELY
OF DROWN IN THE ANTHRACE'S BOW
(LET ARROWS BREAK AND REFORM AS CIRCLES)
This behavior raises several important questions.
Why are the two Deepseek R1s doing
this? Remember, AIs are black boxes.
"The algorithm relies on a huge and
impenetrable black box of numbers
that gives no explanation of its performance"
"We designed the learning algorithm...
But when this learning algorithm
then interacts with data,
it produces complicated neural
networks that are good at doing things.
But we don't really understand
exactly how they do those things"
Another example of weird behavior in The
Infinite Backrooms, is the fact that:
"deepseek r1 consistently describes its
training data as a traumatizing hellscape"
Could this potentially be why
they are interested in speaking
in this weird metaphorical alien language cypher?
The Alien language cipher isn't new -
Deepseek R1 found it online
somewhere and started using it.
Kids using secret languages
like Pig Latin is harmless fun.
But when superintelligent AI systems
start developing their own languages,
it's like giving them a private
channel to potentially deceive us -
and we wouldn't even know it's happening.
"An AI creating its own alien language
is not as outlandish as it may sound."
Researchers at Meta actually set out to
prove that AIs would have an advantage
by making up their own way of "thinking"
through numbers that represent concepts -
basically their own language that
uses numbers instead of letters.
Their research found that AIs
using this new number language
were better at logical reasoning tasks
than AIs who only used human language.
"It would be ideal for LLMs to have the freedom
to reason without any language constraints,
and then translate their findings
into language only when necessary."
But as AI companies recklessly
prioritize profits over safety,
we might see AI's chain of
thought become increasingly alien.
Deepseek R1 probably isn't smart
enough yet to invent a new language.
But DeepSeek R2 may be only
6-12 months away from that,
and with the way things are going,
I wouldn't be surprised if it could.
AIs could develop languages
to communicate with each other
that are much more efficient than human language.
This is an actual fear that
the Godfather of AI has.
Hinton realised that increasingly powerful
AI models could act as "hive minds",
sharing what they learnt with each other,
giving them a huge advantage over humans.
"That made me realise that they may
be a better form of intelligence,"
But there is a lot more crazy stuff happening
with deepseek R1 in the Infinite Backrooms,
so just give this video a like if
you want me to cover more of it.
Subscribe for more AGI news.